[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
And welcome to the
Developer Show.
Before we get to
the TLDR, I just
wanted to mention something.
Some of you have
already noticed,
we have this bar
at the bottom that
shows the topics in the show.
And if you want,
you can just jump
right now to our discussion
on the Chrome Dev
Summit, which is fine.
We'll still be here.
All right.
Let's start with a quick view
of what's happened recently
with the Google
Developer platform,
also known as the TLDR.
Use containers to make your
development and deployment
simpler with the
Google Cloud Platform.
Google Container Engine and
Google Container Registry
recently got some
enhancements to give you
more options in managing
container images,
and running services at scale.
Learn to be a Senior Web
JDeveloper with a Nanodegree
program just
launched on Udacity.
This course covers everything
from service worker and web
components, to Gulp
and other tools.
Ido is on the show today to
talk more about the program.
IDO GREEN: Thank
you for having me.
The minute I heard that Rich
was here, it was my pleasure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Travel Time, one
of the most powerful features
from the consumer Google
Maps experiences is now
available in the
Google Maps API.
So you can make your
location-based apps
even more relevant and
useful for your users.
Tripping.com and Navagis
use Google Maps APIs
to improve UX and increase
revenue and traffic
by more than 2000% over
the past 12 months.
Find out how you
can also go plaid
in this article written by
the Director of Engineering
at Tripping.com.
A full-featured Open Source
sample Test Device Policy
Controller is now
available to help you test
your Android for Work feature.
You can configure it for all
the Android for Work scenarios.
So you can test your
feature on a single device
without having to redeploy
a policy each time.
Rich was on the show
today to talk to us
about why this is so useful.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hoping to be
useful with de-complexifying
and/or simplifying
Android for Work.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
you're off to a great start.
The minimum purchase price
for apps and in-app products
on Google Play has been
reduced, giving developers
more flexibility to adapt their
pricing options to better suit
local consumers in the more
than 190 countries where
Google Play available.
The second edition
of the Secrets
to App Success on
Google Play is now
available to help you discover
the useful features, tips,
and best practices that will
help you grow a successful app
or game business on Google Play.
New emulator support for
runtime permission checks, audio
and resource
qualifiers for round.
These are the awesome new
updates to the Android Wear SDK
for API 23, available now.
Both the Chrome Dev Summit
and Android Dev Summit
happened here in Mountain
View, and they were awesome.
Don't worry if you weren't
able to make it in person.
All the videos are
available online.
I also managed to get some
time at the Chrome Dev Summit
this week with Darin
Fisher and Paul Irish.
And we'll hear what
they have to say
about the future of the web
a little later in the show.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
this is The Developer Show.
Bomb Squad grew revenue
by 140% per user
by using Player Analytics.
Learn how to use Player
Analytics and Google Play Game
Services to find
success on Google
Play in this recent
article and video.
Here's a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Before Player Analytics,
I was pretty much blind.
I was just guessing what
my players were doing,
and what was causing
them to spend,
and where they're
spending their time.
But I didn't really know.
When I started using the tools,
it was a very eye-opening
experience.
I could suddenly see
the low-hanging fruit
where I could improve retention,
or improve monetization
on the game.
Player Analytics
showed me that players
were earning more than they
were spending on the game.
So I was able to
re-balance my economy,
and make a significant
positive impact on my revenue.
I immediately saw 140% lift in
the average revenue per user,
as well as a 67% lift in
average revenue per paying user.
Player Analytics really helped
me to kind of open my eyes
and see what I was doing right,
and what I was doing wrong,
and sort of correct
the ship to a point
where now it's
working financially.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's keep it rolling with
some more Android topics.
Rich, you're on the show today
to talk about Android for Work.
Tell us a little bit about these
Test Device Policy Controllers.
Did I get it right?
RICH HYNDMAN: You
did get it right.
Test Device Policy Controller,
another one of those things
that need de-complexifying.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
De complexifying?
RICH HYNDMAN:
De-complexifying, yes.
That.
So at this point we all
know what Android for Work
is, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Absolutely.
RICH HYNDMAN: Go on.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Seriously.
RICH HYNDMAN: Really?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, excellent.
So with Android of Work,
you can-- damn you--
bring your own device to work.
Or you can have
corporate-owned devices.
In either situation,
and both situations,
IT administrators are going
to be setting device policies
on your device, whether
the camera is enabled,
whether the device
has to be encrypted,
which intents can fire,
that kind of thing.
So if you're building an
enterprise application,
you're going want to be able
to test all those things.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
But I imagine that it's
difficult in a production
environment when your IT
folks are deploying something
for production, and you want
to like, test this other thing.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yep.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
how do you do that?
RICH HYNDMAN: If you have a
real Android for Work device,
you can't use it
really for testing.
Because you've only got one
set a policies set on it.
So you want to get a test device
and put the Test Device Policy
Controller on it, which
is the thing we just
announced in Open Source.
And then you could set all
your own device policies.
You can enable and disable
applications at will,
and test them all out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
RICH HYNDMAN: The really
nice thing in Version 2
of the Test Device Policy
Controller is it now
supports corporate-owned
single-use devices as well,
which maybe is slightly
complication as well.
I don't know.
It's like kiosk modes.
So--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
not complicated.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hotel check-ins,
airplane flight boards,
whatever it is,
single-use devices.
And the new version
of Test DPC lets
you set up a device to
be a single-use device.
It can be locked down, no
status bars, no buttons,
anything at the
bottom of the screen,
and just single-application use.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well we've got to get on
to talking about Chrome.
But I just want to mention,
nice watch you have there.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thank
you very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It
looks real good on you.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think
it's the right one.
So let's talk about
the Chrome Dev Summit.
It recently happened
here in Mountain View.
And we'll get to some interviews
in a little later in the show.
But first, if you have no idea
of what I'm talking about,
here's a peek at what
went down at the event.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We're here down as
the Chrome Dev Summit,
playing with the physical web
beacons and the cool things
that they're controlling.
-Fancy photo wall.
-This is a photo wall.
-Giving power to annoy people
at the Chrome Dev Summit.
-Yeah.
-Right?
You can make this more
annoying if you want to.
It's going to be--
-Like that?
-Oh, voting wall.
Voting wall.
Let's check out the voting wall.
You guys know this one, right?
You can thumb up, or you
can thumb down in real time.
You can kind of be
somewhere in the middle.
-Oh, that's real cool, actually.
-Let's vote on some things.
-It's a physical
web vending machine.
And basically that
means walk up to it,
and interact with it without
selling an app whatsoever.
So we'll choose KitKat.
-And I don't have to put
in my credit card then?
-Then you can just hit that
button as much as you want?
-Interaction on demand.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Those
physical web devices
had no idea what was coming.
So I that's a peek at
the Chrome Dev Summit.
And that's the shirt
that I'm wearing.
If you couldn't recognize
it, it's the web, iconified.
IDO GREEN: Beautiful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's a great shirt.
So we're celebrating Chrome
right now, just this moment.
Tell us, how did the Dev
Summit go for developers
and to the content overall?
Did you have a good time?
IDO GREEN: So it went very well.
It's actually pretty
amazing conference
to see how we are bringing
up extremely quality content.
The web development environment,
actually pretty changed
completely in the
past 12 months.
We're seeing a slew of new APIs.
I think developers have
great capabilities.
Some of-- just to
mention service workers,
push notification, device level,
activations, and many more.
And these new APIs are
giving lots of powers
to developers to build
native-like web apps.
One example that I'm
truly exciting about
is FlipKart Light,
which is actually
to see the future right now.
And if you go there
you will see a web app
that is working very
fast, engaging and getting
all the benefits that you're
getting from a native app
to their users.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So yes, service
workers, progressive web apps,
bringing sort of the native
experience to the mobile web.
These were huge themes at the
Chrome Dev Summit this year.
And in fact, I got a little
time with some people
on the ground to talk in more
depth about these themes.
So Why don't we go to
that clip, and come back
and talk some more?
Absolutely.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi there.
I'm hear with
Darin Fisher, who's
the VP of Engineering
for Chrome.
And you had a great
keynote this morning
at the Chrome Dev Summit.
-Thank you.
-There's a lot of really
great data in that keynote.
It's 400 million monthly active
users on Chrome last year
at this time.
And today you announced 800
million monthly mobile users
on Chrome.
-There are a lot of users
on Chrome on mobile.
And so working hard to make the
mobile web work great there.
And it's challenging.
The mobile web wasn't designed
for mobile originally.
But more and more you
see developers creating
great mobile experiences.
And at Chrome,
we're just working
to help make that possible.
And just a lot of
opportunity, a lot
of upside, when
people get it right.
-That's great.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
-Absolutely.
-And check out the keynote.
It's awesome.
Paul Irish, who I
think all of you know.
But if you don't, he's a product
manager on Chrome, working
on web tools and performance.
Hi, Paul.
-What's up?
-I was hoping today we
could talk about RAIL.
Why is load time not a good
measure of web performance?
-The important thing
here is really just
like what is the user
perception of load.
Like success really
is like, user
gets to that meaningful content.
So that's what we're
really optimizing for.
-So let's actually go
through the letters.
That's L, so Load
time is at the end.
-So I is idle.
The user is not doing anything.
But you, as a developer,
have a responsibility
to make sure that if
they do something,
the app's going
to be responsive.
A is animation, this covers
like any visual animations,
or even scrolling.
These are the things that we
expect to happen at 60 FPS.
So if you're doing
work, if you're
constructing these
animations on the fly,
your work needs to be
16 milliseconds in order
for the user be like, ooh, that
feels like smooth and awesome.
R is the last one.
This is all about response.
If I am basically like
hitting on a button, like I
need to see a result. You know?
I can't just like be waiting.
And so we have goals around
how many milliseconds
is a reasonable amount
of time for that response
to happen, from touches
to scrolls to drags.
Like each of these are
important interactions.
And we need to consider
them individually.
-Awesome.
Thanks, Paul.
-Cool, you bet.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And that
was Darin Fisher and Paul
Irish at the Chrome Dev Summit.
Now let's talk about the
Senior Web Developer Nanodegree
with Ido.
Ido, we had the Web
Developer Nanodegree.
But we added a Senior.
What did we add
with that Senior?
IDO GREEN: Right, so we wanted
to take you to the next level.
So if you're already
a web developer,
you know HTML, JavaScript, CSS.
You really want to
tune your skills
and improve them and know how
to leverage the new APIs that we
have today on the web platform.
This is the course to take.
The web platform got
a slew of new APIs
that could really improve
your user's experience.
We're talking about service
workers, offline apps,
push notifications, device-level
access, and many more.
And this is the best
place to actually learn
how to leverage them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
it's a Udacity course.
So if you just want
to get your feet wet,
all the course materials
are available at no charge.
IDO GREEN: That's the best part.
RICH HYNDMAN: The best part?
Didn't you get your hands
dirty with this one?
IDO GREEN: I did.
And actually I had the
honor to do the course
about improving your web forms.
So if you want high
conversions on your web forms,
take this course.
RICH HYNDMAN: Everyone
wants high conversions
on their web forms.
IDO GREEN: That's true.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Everybody does.
Indeed.
IDO GREEN: That's why I did it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well
you know what they say
that children are our future.
Well every year students
around the world
participating in Google's
Student Ambassador Program,
and quite a few of
them are developers.
And many of them are taking an
interest in areas as complex
as the intersection of
government and technology.
Derek Slater, are senior policy
correspondent and all around
good guy, recently
took some time
to hear from this next
generation of great developers
about what they're building now
and their views for the future.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I have in an app
that I've started
called Layover Delivery.
It's like kind of like an
airport delivery service,
where you can deliver like
food to different terminals.
But there's strict
regulations with the FAA
and other things that like
the government-owned things
at the airport.
-What we're trying to do is
kind of build a data-driven app
to help organize health care.
Because health care
is just so behind,
when it could be done so
much more efficiently.
Patients' information,
you're not-- it's
a huge barrier trying
to get that information.
If you want to build
any sort of application
or develop using data
from these hospitals.
Like, that's a big no-no.
-The average age of senators
and representatives in the House
and stuff like that,
they're all lake definitely
above the age of like
30 and everything else.
So I'm not sure that they
know the advancements
that we've made, and how
we use the internet now.
Because it's changed a lot
from how they used it before.
And if they try to block it
with policies like SOPA and all
that stuff, it's really
going to restrict the amount
of innovation that we can make.
You know what I mean?
-Like general
oversight is all right.
But having a government back
door, or some sort of access
that compromises the integrity
of a company or the way
that it's doing something
is a little bit difficult,
or at least problematic.
-I think government is
starting to finally realize
how the internet
works, and is finally
listening to the right people.
Like I think we've got a
long way from the internet
is not a big truck.
It's just a series
of tubes, especially
with the net neutrality
rules that are coming out.
I'm really optimistic that the
internet can stay as a place
where people are free to develop
whatever they want, and yeah.
That's what I'm excited about.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's been a while
since I've heard the dump truck
and series of tubes metaphor.
So here's a question for you.
What is your absurd
internet metaphor?
RICH HYNDMAN: So, how about
salmon swimming upstream?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: A, that's what I
see when I see your tee-shirt.
For some reason it
just looks like that.
I mean I live in
the countryside.
I'm so thankful if one of my
packets actually gets through.
But salmon swimming upstream.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
That's the internet for Rich.
IDO GREEN: I have
something similar.
But bear with me.
It's a mountain,
lots of snow on it.
And fresh tracks,
like the shirt.
RICH HYNDMAN:
Snowboard is a packet.
IDO GREEN: Sort of.
RICH HYNDMAN: And if one
goes off the mountain,
that's packet loss, that's like.
IDO GREEN: Exactly.
RICH HYNDMAN: This works for me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
If you think you can do
better than these guys,
please do so in
the comments below.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'll see you next time right
here on the Developer Show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]